I'm tank Sinatra and I'm back to answer
the internet who is the one person in
the world you would least want to bang
your significant other because most is
easy no I'm kidding I mean anybody could
it's not
whatever at this point right at least
who do I I'll tell you something like
what if what if your wife had sex with
Jay-Z oh I would ask her to tell me the
detailed description of it is sex with
conjoined twins a threesome yeah I would
say so is the do they have two sexual
organs this is the question
it is because there's another brain
involved ostensibly unless they share a
brain these are these are the questions
when you're having sex with
sex organs making a threesome
both
um one vagina and two girl brains is
that a threesome if they are connected
at the head and it's one brain and two
vaginas and you're popping back and
forth
why do we ask these questions
um I I believe
I believe it is a threesome in any
variation in any variation because
either it's two brains and two vaginas
or one brain and one vagina no that's
one that's just sex uh
oh no dude I hope I never have to figure
it out I hope I do would you rather have
wet socks for a whole year or a
year-long cold
uh
[Music]
uh I'd rather die
um
well if you have wet socks for a year
you're going to get many colds you know
they say that that sounds like some old
[__] [__] your mom or grandma told
you I do that every once in a while and
it [__] feels good you get it
it's warm water first of all
once a year an annual yeah so wait
they're like every let's just say eight
nine ten months have gone by you're just
like it's time to do it you step in the
[__] tub with your socks on whatever
and it feels good are we talking like
like tube socks local like I only I only
have uh ankle socks so it's still but
your feet are just soaking and you're
and you're washing and [__] washing and
my feet are like insulated it's like
wearing a wetsuit for your feet so I
could actually getting in in the water
in a wetsuit is a funny yeah and it's
kind of like a wetsuit for your feet
yeah I'm gonna do it tonight yeah let me
know how it goes if there was a snail
following you for the rest of your life
and if you touched it you'd die how long
could you survive is it agile it's it's
still just a regular snail Moves In A
Snail's Pace same you know and it can't
be killed or whatever only has the
dexterity of a snail it can't Spiderman
into it okay I feel like I've lived
forever I think so yeah I feel like I'd
be able to outsmart the snail as smart
as the snail may be but you don't
just don't know
like every time you lay your head down
at night you'd be like did the snail
make its way well you know what I you
know people eat eight spiders a year or
whatever it is I never go to bed
thinking about actually now that I say
that maybe a week maybe I'd survive a
week with this now because I would
forget about it like so even if you hop
on a plane and leave it's like well what
if it made its way to [__] LaGuardia
that by in 24 hours and it got on a
plane too and you're I mean you know but
then be comfortable
I'm never comfortable anyway so you just
have to always be like go listen I have
not to you know uh be one of these guys
but I live in a pretty anxious State I
have of constant anxiety not
overwhelming or you know yeah killer but
I feel like this is no different I feel
like this is now following me at all
times anyway would you rather be a
world-class dancer world-class singer or
world class fighter can you
can you I don't like to you can throw
hands a little bit though yeah if I mean
if I had to no but I mean like to have
you like boxed like you've done it or
you're like you're just a big guy and
you can hold it no I I mean I I did
martial arts when I was young and then I
stopped and then I did boxing and then I
stopped and then I did Jiu Jitsu and
then I stopped I enjoy it listen if if
some guy on the street when I walk out
of here tries to rob me and like doesn't
just ask me but actually tries to and he
doesn't have a weapon you're good I'm
good I'm not there's no fear unless the
guy is tremendous but even if he's
tremendous I know how to figure it out
and I also figured out I used to be so
terrified of fighting um until I figured
out that hey it doesn't really hurt when
you get punched in the face in a fight
it just the adrenaline is so high yeah
it hurts after but I also don't like
hurting people so
I would like to be a world-class singer
I would like to be able
yeah like I joined the Opera immediately
I would apply and join I would just show
up and start singing and blow
everybody's Minds if there was stats
available for every aspect of your life
what one stat would you want to see this
is going to sound so annoying but I
would like to know how many people
I had a truly positive impact on
I would like to know how many people
like my dad it definitely is annoying
but it's a good one too yeah I know I'm
sorry like my dad uh we had every time
we had a birthday party for him this guy
would get invited and every time he
would see me he'd go your dad is a great
man he really is he's an unbelievable
human being and I'd be like that is this
guy gay like what is this what is his
deal with you so I finally asked him and
he said oh this guy was having a tough
day one time and I told him you know I
told him something and he really
appreciated it it's like changed the
guy's life so I just want to know how
many people if they're already out there
that I did thanks good news alone I'm
sure you've reached three four if your
life depended on it what gymnastics
event Would You Bet Your Life that you
could do
oh my God gymnastic events yeah you're
pretty flexible
um I don't know if I'd say I'm pretty
flexible I can touch it for your size if
you can touch your toes I would think
you're flexible yeah like the final bird
like touches his knees really he goes
like this he's like uh yeah like oh yeah
you're very flexible yeah I've heard
people say like I can dance for a guy in
my size I'm flexible for a guy my size
so you got tumbling you got the Rings
the pommel horse the balance beam for
regime just get out there and Shake It
Whatever
tumbling yeah floor routine or the I'll
tell you what I wouldn't [__] do the
uneven bars this is not a shot in hell I
wouldn't crack my skull open you would
break that [__] I like to think I'd be
able to but then I know the first
attempt of going from that bar to that
bar it's over I think the I would do the
parallel bars because that's like dips I
could do a lot of dips I could probably
do some things
in a row
40. Jesus that's [__] is that a lot I
mean there's a lot I have push-ups you
can't do any
no no no oh yeah uh maybe I could maybe
30. what is your best thing you can do
um
for push-ups I could probably I also
weigh 250 pounds yeah so pull-ups I
could do probably 15 uh which is great
because as a fat kid I did zero and it
was devastating there's no embarrassing
embarrassing then when you're the whole
school the whole class is watching and
you're just like yeah that's it they're
like okay you can go it's like I'm
trying yeah yeah you're not going
anywhere yeah you did zero pull-ups it
took you half an hour to run the 600 you
fat [__] what are you doing where are
your parents
yeah
could you beat Tom Cruise in a fight I
would beat the [__] out of Tom Cruise no
I wouldn't want to but if it was me and
him I had a decent I don't give a [__]
dude I don't care
he's 60 years old
first of all he's not really he's like
like a
scientologists
bro he stopped Aging in like 1985. he's
got all that that that like it's it's
movie training but it's still training
it's training yeah for sure very good
shape he's crazy
listen if it was would you would you
could you beat Tom Cruise in uh an
American ninja course no
but I would smother Tom Cruise and choke
him out most people who answer this
question I'm like no tacos and smoke you
I think you would beat the [__] out of
time I I mean especially if I had like a
month to train for it yeah dude I think
you just kind of like he's so small dude
I'm so big I'm 250 pounds I'm like two
of him
he would be like fighting a child
I would have loved to have seen Justin
Bieber and Tom Cruise fight when Justin
Bieber challenged him to a boxing match
out of nowhere I would have loved to
seen that but that's the kind of [__] if
I had like billions of dollars I would
make that
happen name your price fellas like yeah
whatever you guys want I'll donate I
already like we have to make this happen
yeah maybe we can still do it one day if
anybody could do it it's Barstool get
him in the next rough and rowdy
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out